Black Mirror season 6 has an insane
amount of Easter eggs with references
going all the way back to season one so
I thought it would be fun to put them
all together in one big video to see
just how small our block Mirror Universe
is keep in mind this will be a spoiler
video and if you've seen my other Black
Mirror videos some of this will be a bit
of a rehash although I'll be going into
a bit more detail now let's make like
the mysterious Eggman and lock Henry and
find some eggs a new addition to this
season is streamberry the netflix-esque
streaming platform where you can find
such great programming as the Calo ears
and lock Henry Davis will actually
receive a congratulatory note from them
after winning a bafta for his
documentary ironically it's in the shape
of a mask just like what his mother wore
when she would kill when Joan and Krish
snuggle up to watch an evening of prime
streamberry programming were inundated
with tons of Easter egg content the
first is mad mind a documentary on
Jerome F Davis the author of the book
Stefan video game bandersnatch is based
on tuckersoft the company that made
bandersnatch has its logo on the back of
Davis's laptop you can also make out the
7g Tucker soft Network on the phones in
Joan is awful more laptop logos include
archangels a company where a chip can be
inserted into your child to track their
location and censor them from
distressing Material there's Waldo the
animated character who ran for office
and in a news ticker in lockhenry will
see that he wins an election in Italy
finally there's the white bear logo this
is from season two's a white bear in
which criminals undergo daily
psychological punishment the main
character from that episode is named
Victorious scalene and scalene just
happens to be the name of the law
offices Joan goes to in Joan is awful
speaking of Joan is awful it features
Irma Thomas's anyone who knows what love
is a song that appears in five other
Black Mirror episodes The White Bear
symbol can also be seen in episode 3 as
Kappa in his arranged followers smeared
in blood in David's home after murdering
his family it can also be seen on the
cursed Domino Talisman in Demon 79 and
also Incorporated in Michael Smart's
Britannia party speaking of which smart
is the name of a streamberry documentary
based on British MP Michael smart who
first makes an appearance in episode 5's
demon 79 he's arguably the most
referenced character this season
appearing in several articles and new
stickers across the episodes which in
and of themselves tell a story in Demon
79 we see that he's running as the
Conservative candidate in tipley with a
secret agenda of booting out all the
immigrants and restoring Britain to its
white Heritage in lockhenry we learned
that he was a booted out of the Tories
for remarks on immigrants overstaying
their welcome and vows to start a new
party in Demon 79 Nita sees a vision of
the future which sees Michael becoming
prime minister in it he's established a
platoon of metal police dogs a reference
to season 4's Metalhead a new sticker in
lock Henry shows that they've just been
unveiled even Davis is a small metal dog
in his childhood room the next
strawberry original is spacefleet and
not to season Four's USS Callister a
spacefleet movie is even playing at the
theater the Ross family attends in
episode 3's beyond the sea in the
Articles found in Demon 79 the mayor of
tipley is named Walton while the
Publican who died in The Blaze was daily
these are the names of the protagonist
and antagonist in USS Callister Aaron
Paul also voices the character gamer 691
in that episode The Articles themselves
are written by a Nicholas Murray who
happens to be in the art department on
the show what are the biggest shows on
streamberry is Sea of Tranquility which
has references going all the way back to
season one in national anthem the
special effects expert hired to fake the
Prime Minister shagging a pig says he
worked on that show in nosedive a few
characters chat about attending a
Tranquility con based on characters from
the show and in Smithereens we can #sea
of Tranquility reboot is trending this
reboot is also mentioned in Rachel Jack
and Ashley 2 where reporter announces
the news funny enough this reporter also
mentions the singer by the name of Tusk
who's getting canceled over some of his
remarks in Joan is awful we'll see him
send out a tweet saying you hashtag
can't cancel me in episode 4 we'll meet
Justin camley an actor known for his
role in Sea of Tranquility I guess
they'll need to recast him not so much
Easter eggs as fun little details but
the episode Maisie day sprinkles
werewolf foreshadowing from Paw Prints
outside the nightclub and a full moon
outside maisie's Hideout but the
Quagmire nightclub is also the name of
this sexy Club in San Junipero finding
ripman as the next stream Berry program
with an Easter egg connection Colin
Rittman was a video game designer found
in bandersnatch in episode 4's Maisy day
the cop at the diner's last name is
Ritman but it's never mentioned if
they're related there's also Hot Shot
the virtual talent show whose winners
can live a life of luxury from season
one 115 million merits in lock Henry we
can see that auditions for the show have
opened in Sydney Rowdy and peanut is
also a nod to the animated show cat
burglar which was written by Charlie
Brooker the showrunner of Black Mirror
from the creators of Locke Henry comes
the callow years a documentary on
British Prime Minister Michael callow
who had to have sex with a pig we'll see
the same poster at the historic offices
in Locke Henry there's even a brief
mention of him on a tabloid article
stating that he's now running a zoo
which is really interesting since in
season Four's nosedive he's seen posting
just got thrown out of the zoo again
even crazier as this article Nida
stumbles upon from the early 20th
century which talks about an MP named
callow having to step down due to an
altercation with an animal could the
animal love run in the callow family and
a quick reminder if you like these types
of videos be sure to like And subscribe
every little bit helps the channel out
unfortunately only half of these shows
can be seen on the streamberry app we've
already talked about black bear over
here but you can make Take Out Victoria
scalene's boyfriend who she committed
murder with beside her next is bother
guts the name of a show characters in
season 1's 15 million merits can watch
while peddling for points you may also
recognize Miley Cyrus's Ashley o music
video on a roll which was a prominent
aspect of season 5's Rachel Jack and
Ashley too in season 5 Smithereens we
can see that she's performing at Wembley
Stadium finally there's Junipero
dreaming a nod to San Junipero in
episode 1 Joan complains about some
terrible coffee while at her therapist
this is from a coffee shop called
Yorkies the same chain Beau will work at
in episode 4. Yorkie also happens to be
the name of the main character in San
Junipero and a contact in Pia's phone in
lockhenry a Yorkshire Terrier a Yorkie
can also be found in this stream Berry
program fancy dogs last days and
considering Yorkie experiences her last
days in San Junipero I don't think it's
a stretch that this is a nod to that
while browsing his phone Jones x max
sees a tweet by no those die protagonist
Lacey pound and when Sandy is alerted to
the new Jonas awful television show you
can see a message from The Smithereens
app the Uber style Rideshare company
seen in season 5. there are also some
characters this season who have been in
previous Black Mirror episodes the
lawyer in Jonah's awful is played by
wunmi musaku who you may remember from
season 3's play test Nita from demon 79
played a character named space cop in
nosedive and the guy who played Dr
Dimitri babich played Jim in season 2's
the Waldo moment while reading about
stringberry we see an article stating
grains going out of style a reference to
the memory grains which record all
memories found in season ones the entire
history of you one of the books Pia
scans and lock Henry is called a river
of death pretty ironic considering how
she dies also in lock Henry a ticker
that reads U.S tourist found dead at
Saito Gamu a reference to season 3's
play test Saito Gemma was the developer
of season 5's fighting game striking
vipers in which players could inhabit
the bodies of their fighter in
Smithereens we'll see that hashtag
saitugeemu announcement is trending
which may be a reference to a
partnership with Netflix in Beyond the
Sea David's character in Cliff's replica
visits a Bookshop called Cooper's books
this may be a not to Cooper from season
3's play test the demon Gap calls his
demon superiors using the number 666 and
Michael smart listens to Richard
Wagner's tanhauser Overture the composer
being a known anti-semite at the baftas
there are two other nominees that are up
against Locke Henry one is called suffer
the children about a typically
pedophilia ring tipley was the setting
of demon 79 and we know that a character
from that Tim Simon abused his own
daughter so this hints that there might
be a larger pedo ring in town the second
nominee is titled euthanasia inside
project Junipero all about season 3's
San Junipero in which people could have
their consciousnesses uploaded to a
digital Cloud to live forever that's all
the Black Mirror Easter eggs I found
this season are there any I left out let
me know your favorite in the comments
below and what you thought about this
season thanks for watching please make
sure to like And subscribe and for more
bad takes you can follow me on Twitter
and Instagram at thinkstoryyt until next
time remember hey how are you doing out
there cool
foreign